ask any influencer if you go to La and
you don't blow your entire monthly
grocery budget on like a snack or smooth
ier one are you even influencing like
sometimes when I see the prices on some
people's Air1 grocery hauls I think are
they trolling us like a bottle of water
for 26 bucks coconut yogurt for 24 bucks
chili for 31 or a glass bottle with a
couple tea bags and some water in it for
30 USD the Big D and not even the D we
want to see so that like this is
not even about getting the best quality
food it's really about aligning yourself
with an image of privilege and class and
even if you were to be like a
30-something millionaire you don't stay
Rich spending thirty dollars on like
ground up almonds when you can invest
those 27 and get the exact same thing
that's just stupid in my opinion so
let's take a few of arawan's most
popular Ready-to-Eat recipes strip them
of their BS and pretense and make them
for a fraction of the price because
I would rather buy shoes I'm really
excited about this I haven't actually
been to erwan yet so I have not yet
experienced the cruxshittery in real
life but a lot of people are saying that
their food bar items are actually pretty
good but I'm also pretty sure people
have to convince themselves of that when
they spend their entire weekly grocery
budget on lunch first up let's talk
smoothies there are so many overpriced
over hyped smoothies on erwan's menu
like it is really going to be hard to
choose so let's just stick with the
celebrity endorsed collabs we've got
Bella Hadid Kourtney Kardashian and
Haley Bieber I'm gonna say we go with
Haley today because her 17 strawberry
glazed skin smoothie definitely got a
lot of hype online so according to
various sources online this recipe
contains almond milk dates vanilla
collagen CMOS coconut cream maple syrup
hyaluronic acid strawberries avocado
vanilla Stevia and a little strawberry
glaze for garnish I don't think we can
do without the BS and save ourselves
some coin let's do it all right
strawberries we can do
I went a little crazy
but I got all my ingredients at Walmart
and the frozen strawberries were on sale
so I figured this is a great time to use
them lots of vitamin C and lots of fiber
we got avocado healthy fats and fiber we
have our vanilla collagen
in here and I'm going to add a half
scoop of vanilla plant-based protein
powder which gives us a much more
favorable amino acid profile for skin
nails and for satiety and muscle protein
synthesis easy little tip there I got
two dates the recipe that I found called
for pits in but I think that's a bad
idea
and then a little maple syrup
I think we can skip the vanilla Stevia
because the dates plus the strawberries
plus the protein powder plus the maple
syrup it's sweet enough for this girl
and then we just blend her together with
a little almond milk
looks about right
foreign
I'm gonna skip the CMOS and the
hyaluronic acid because I don't feel
like spending a hundred dollars just in
shipping alone just to make a smoothie
for your viewing pleasure especially
when I know that I'm unlikely to use it
again and it's also unlikely to do
anything measurable in a milkshake but
in case you're wondering CMOS is of
course Very nutritious similar to other
seaweeds so it's a source of live
bacteria and prebiotics plus a really
high source of iodine but the research
that we have the supports use for gut
health has been done on rats so we
really don't know what kind of dosage we
would need in humans to see any kind of
measurable result plus as a supplement
it's not well regulated so you could
very well be ending up with higher than
expected levels of iodine which can
negatively affect the thyroid in some
folks as for the hyaluronic acid it is
an evidence-based supplement especially
for joint health but because this is the
skin smoothie I'm assuming that the use
of hyaluronic acid is for skin
elasticity and wrinkle prevention and
the research showing benefits used
around 200 milligrams of hyaluronic acid
and I would be shocked if arawan was
adding more than a few drops so I'm just
going to skip that save your money
invest in a really nice spa day or a
really good quality hyaluronic acid
based night cream which is probably far
more effective than an occasional trip
to erwan so Haley's Smoothie has some
homemade strawberry glaze as she calls
it I'm just going to use some Chia
strawberry jam here definitely could
have made my own but I'm lazy like that
that oh yeah this is gonna be good and
then she takes some coconut cream puts a
little there on the sides
who the would do this in real life
I don't know but I guess it's for the
gram Jackson Pollock here all right this
is going to be good A little poor action
[Music]
if your straw doesn't match the shirt
why bother so this recipe cost me 2.80
as opposed to the 17 if you went to air
one plus I have the added benefit of
some extra protein in there which
Haley's recipe does not have
hmm
oh yeah she is so good success okay
let's talk salads so everyone has a
bunch of influencer backed salads but I
have seen a million posts about the kale
and white bean salad
hello do you not know that there is a
YouTube star in here filming sorry about
that so the ingredients in this are
pretty self-explanatory we got kale we
got white beans avocado a bunch of seeds
we love it my instacart app so I'd be
spending about 19 a pound on this salad
and I've seen lots of other reports of
people saying that they spent anywhere
between 14 to 20 bucks so yeah that
pretty much does check out but guys this
is so easy please do not spend this kind
of money on this
I know
it's gonna be weeks of this they say you
can't make friends with salad but I am
determined to prove them wrong whoever
them is I'm gonna make a serving in one
bowl just to make it super simple all
right a little bit of tahini as our base
a little bit of mustard a little hint of
maple
salt tapa some lemon
flino seeds
still got a seed in there oh I can't
make a damn dressing without burning
your hangnail mix that together and if
you need to thin it out a little bit you
just add a splash of water tap water
controversial I know
nice next got some kale kale could not
be more affordable when you compare it
to all them other greens out there so
please do not spend money on pre-made
kale mixes we're gonna massage the out
of it now massaging kale is not just a
pleasurable Pastime it actually has a
purpose we want to start to break down
some of those tough fibers so it makes
it a lot easier to digest and also just
more enjoyable to chew on I mean I don't
know about you guys but I don't have two
hours to eat a salad at lunch give her
some love nice all right we're gonna
throw in some white beans great source
of protein to pair with our fiber give
that a toss in the dressing noise
[Music]
all right then let's serve her up
we got avocado for our healthy fats and
we finished it off
with lots of pumpkin seeds and my
favorite hemp hearts tons of healthy
fats fiber and protein this is a very
generous portion for 2.80 like why would
you do it any other way
understand the hype not the price
for our main today let's do erwan's
coconut turmeric chicken fingers there's
been a lot of chatter about these
chicken fingers online which is actually
kind of sad that there's like chatter
about a grocery store hot bar item but I
guess everyone loves their tendies so
their version has a combination of
coconut cornmeal and brown rice flour
and then they do buttermilk and coconut
milk for the dredge which is really
strange to me because like why would
they just keep it dairy free they could
put more letters at the end of the
recipe and probably charge more for it
but anyways my app said that these would
cost me 26 dollars a pound and
considering how easy they are to make at
home we can definitely do better than
that so let's do it I'm gonna use almond
flour instead of the brown rice flour
the erwan uses it's got lots of healthy
fats and protein unsweetened coconut we
got tahin
some lime zest
salt pepper and turmeric
because if you put a pinch of turmeric
in it you can charge twice as much for
it all right for the wet we got an egg
little splash of coconut milk a juice of
half a lime
and I just like to season every layer a
little salt and pepper
all right so I got some chicken breasts
that I cut into
strips adding some salt now we dip
weren't
you need a wet hand
and a dry hand
that is the key let's pop this into a
400 degree oven for 20 to 25 minutes
flipping it halfway through
five hours later this right here worked
out to two dollars and 40 cents when I
bought the ingredients at Walmart not
bad recession not bad
the flavor so good you don't even need
the dip um
[Applause]
the tahin takes it to the next level air
on take notes
hmm you can't go to erwan apparently and
not get their buffalo cauliflower for a
cool price of twenty dollars per pound
based on what I read online their
ingredients include brown rice flour
oregano arrowroot nutritional yeast and
then they fry it in a rice bran oil and
also funny that they use rice bran oil
which does have an unfavorable omega-6
to Omega-3 ratio but maybe it just
sounds a little boozier than canola oil
that's marketing baby move the money
from your client's pocket into your
pocket right but if you can make clients
money at the same time it's advantageous
to everyone correct no honestly I have
no interest in sticking up my whole
house deep frying so we're gonna bake
ours which will make our recipe a little
healthier a little bit more nutritious
than just a bunch of healthified
ingredients so let's do it
I got some whole wheat flour here
instead of the brown rice flour way more
accessible and in my opinion more
nutritious their recipe has oregano
nutritional yeast great source of B12
and protein a little Cayenne or a kick
salt oh
and pepper gave her a stir
and to make the batter we're going to
add some non-dairy milk I'm using this
kind of protein milk just to get a
little bit extra protein in there seeing
as this is just a vegetable side and
we're just gonna eyeball it until it
gets to like the right texture still a
little bit too
thick
I think this will do it that'll do it
nice all right gonna spray my baking pan
coat these bad boys get them coated in
the batter oh I'm an escape artist
oh
all right
pop them onto our baking sheets make
sure they're super separated no one can
touch anyone else so they can get really
crispy no clumps no steaming throw this
into a 450 degree oven for about 20
minutes until they're golden brown
all right
a few moments later looking good step
one done we got cauliflower let's make a
buffalo style so I've got some Frank's
Red Hot here that's going to take
forever more
that much a little bit of melted vegan
butter obviously you can use regular
butter give it a swirl oh the crunchy
bits that's all the good stuff in we go
quickly into the pool
toast everybody in everybody in
you don't want them to get too soggy so
you gotta move your body I've never
worked in a professional kitchen but I
know that they do this a lot make sure
it's well oiled back out we go oh my God
it tastes so good already the smell of
vision my mouth is just
watering oh can't wait to get you in my
mouth all right 10 more minutes at 450
and now we eat this is a whole head of
cauliflower so if we want to serve this
as a little appy or side for poor people
we're down to a dollar 20 per serving I
oink
why would you do cauliflower any other
way
so what do we learn here folks well you
can spend 55 dollars on lunch at erwan
or you could spend nine dollars and
probably make it a lot more nutritious
in the process and now I've got meal
prep for the week we love it so if you
guys like this type of video please give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you'd like to see more if
you've got other recipes that you want
to see me recreate if you want to see
more overpriced bougie arawan recipes
get at me I will do it for you also
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel ring that little bell and if
you're looking for more 100 question
combos hit up the description to get my
free Hunger crushing combo ebook alright
thanks guys
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]